bro an adult tick-tock house that's
uh this is what it looks like from
morning till 5 p.m in our
adult tick tock house why would you even
call it
like why would you call it a tick tock
house why wouldn't it just roommates
what do you mean
yeah what do you mean yeah that's just
that's just living
in like as an adult like
i went to their page and like you know
most of their tick tocks don't have that
many views and it's like it's not
and this whole thing is is advertising
the real jobs they have
yeah which are not real jobs just
[ __ ] roommates
it's called a tick tock house when it's
all you do yeah
and it's your career they're also not
real jobs
i know that's the best part always like
sorry go ahead
this person is a life coach
[Laughter]
like this person is a is a meditation
guru
what does that even mean man how do you
get paid to do that
bro i was yeah i mean i'll expand on
that in a second but
you know basically what this is is this
is just [ __ ] like you know taylor
knife but they can choose when they want
to do drugs
yeah you know like they can willingly
get on drugs
they don't have to um they don't have to
wait for the fame to
to catch up to them they're just doing
them now yeah cocaine by the way
if you don't know what we're talking
about you go back and watch the last
bonus episode it's probably one of my
favorites that we filmed
oh yeah oh man man it's so good man
dark story all right here we go with the
with the boy
let me run let me start this over oh
come on dude
oh come on dude yeah wait
i'm just gonna start over i gotta hear
the guys no i gotta hear the guys yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah this is gonna get
copyrighted because the [ __ ] music
is it yeah it is okay yeah here wait go
back
start it over let let me just i'll just
do the voiceover
okay all right this is even better
the fact that you're gonna try this all
right and scene okay
here's what a day in the honey host
looks like it's our adult tick tock
house
sam filming workouts on youtube plus
apps with her team
dio agency plus brand strategy
he no dude it's so good the [ __ ] he says
is so good
man we could just get a what if we just
like you know
break it up line by line and advises a
lot of better few brands so she's always
sitting here on her computer
crush crushing it crushing it dude
this guy was hilarious jared is a
fitness trainer and actor so whenever
he's not reading his
sides he's working out i'm like this
dude's really eating a sandwich and
doing
curls with his left arm what is this a
[ __ ] cartoon
you know what's also funny is that like
reading sides and workouts are two
things that take one hour
yes yeah you can [ __ ] memorize any
audition in one hour you can do any
workout in an hour
what else are you what do you mean when
he's not doing this he's doing this
it's like well then what about the other
20 [ __ ] hours of the day
these people just have to be in there
like
yeah i oh wait he was a fitness trainer
oh i see
yeah i'll be training other people yeah
whatever this guy this guy's my favorite
mindset and personal development he's
like one of these like accountability
coaches
he said he's the dude goes he's on the
phone all day getting people
fired up like this dude it's just
all like deep into the day like two
o'clock in the afternoon he's calling
some guy in like [ __ ]
i don't know singapore or some [ __ ] he
was about to go into his night shift and
he's like hey man you [ __ ] ready
like who's paying this guy to hype him
up
that's what i'm that's what i'm wha dude
with these jobs
my biggest point of confusion with this
is
how how the [ __ ] do you start
advertising yourself as this
yeah how do you make a decision one day
these i'm pretty good at getting people
fired up
and you literally build yourself a
squarespace website that says life coach
or whatever the [ __ ]
and then you what do you do like you
email people like how would you feel
good about that yeah i mean bro also you
peep that chess board on the ground
my guy is a [ __ ] thinker all day
every day dude oh yeah
critical thinker yeah i don't know how
you get started as a mindset and
personal development guy
that that part is um i mean it just has
to be
i can only imagine all these jobs start
by [ __ ] somebody's wife
honestly yeah he [ __ ] somebody's wife
and then she's like i want to see you
more but we can't keep doing this
what if you're like my personal
development coach and then he's like oh
yeah and he like builds a website
and then you know that's his one client
and then
her husband becomes his mentor because
she's like he's so great and he's like
you know i should introduce
you know what you do for my wife you
could do for my other friends other
wives and then this all this guy is
actually doing is [ __ ] rich guys
wives
because the unspoken thing is the rich
guy just wants to outsource the rich
guys
that's his phone call right now yeah is
all right beverly hilton cool i'll be
there in
30 minutes i'll be there and knock your
[ __ ] lights out
all these rich guys word mandarin hotel
okay cool yeah yeah okay mandre hotel
this is
narrator yeah he's so good at getting
people fired up all day
i'm gonna [ __ ] your [ __ ] brains out
right now all these rich guys are
passing around his card
like oh man i haven't i haven't [ __ ]
my wife in years i just hired
this personal development guy nick he's
great [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of her i can
just keep working
i can just keep poisoning foreign
countries with
all kinds of business assets and [ __ ]
and then he just he just takes care of
that thing at home
yeah that's what it really is yeah but
you know
mindset hey babe you don't have to worry
that he doesn't love you because i love
you
oh my god nick can we do this full-time
oh well you know you know my rates all
right why don't we
why don't we why don't you bring me to
your place sometime
i think my roommates are really into
that i live with like 12
people 12 people yeah
the irony is that as a mindset personal
development coach
is it's not a it's not a high paying job
it's not a lucrative
job it's it's a good job but it's not
lucrative you know you definitely earn
your dollar
yeah you know this is some this is some
blue-collar dick appointment type stuff
you know this ain't no thing on the side
yeah
[Laughter]
all right who else does we have oh yeah
he's like evan and dina are models and
trainers so when they're not
doing photo shoots they're working out
it's like that's not
what like these are the people where it
takes an hour
yeah maybe two and then you say and then
there's me and brothers me
someone screwed a little bit of
everything lol someone screencapped a
comment
from this dude on this video he's like
and we have poc in the house
i know i saw that too just like someone
was like wow all white people and he was
like no we have poc
in the house too no
and then the person was like but they're
so they're not good enough for the video
or what like
oh my god oh my god
yeah you know what's funny is that
someone was like all these jobs are just
they only exist in la and i was like
yeah it's just so funny thinking about
like a personal development coach
existing and
yeah cleveland oh yeah i mean
personal development coach anywhere else
is just a drug dealer yeah exactly
yeah hey man you want to feel better i
got something for you
yeah that's all it is
what else is is here
what what the [ __ ] is this
him and his girl posting pregnancy
updates on her only fans charging 10
a subscription to see baby bump pictures
what the [ __ ] i hate this so that's how
they pay for the house is only fans no
it's fake though
they said it's fake oh they look like
them
they look like them got it yeah this is
just like you know
uh attractive people doing mundane [ __ ]
and you know it's pretty
it's pretty absurd yeah no this this is
like you couldn't write a better bit
than this
it's like did and and there's no shame
about them either like yeah
we're all hot yeah we're all hot we live
in this house
and like we just [ __ ] play games all
day yeah
[ __ ] sick if we're not working out or
reading sides we're playing
fun ping-pong ball games and filming it
i cannot imagine
this being fun i don't even know if they
actually live here like i just feel like
they clock into this [ __ ] as a job
i want to know how big this house
actually is wait go back to the first
video that we watched because
he does like a he says this is the house
right here
oh yeah like is it a mansion no it's
like it's like open the hills
okay you know what we have to get the
first line of this [ __ ] we have to let
everyone hear the first line of this
[ __ ] video because it's just too good
the honey house i'm gonna i'm gonna let
it run all the way through
okay yeah yeah good good call yeah it's
basically one of these apartment
conversations on youtube plus apps with
their team
dio he's a brand strategy god he's
totally able to
[ __ ] be uh be meditation plus mindset
coach
she'll get you zen the [ __ ] out pretty
much
and then uh aaron she's the only one
with a real job
e-commerce e-commerce brand strategy
yeah
but even that she could just be drop
shipping like anal beads or something
a dropshipping anal beats to nick's
clients
everything revolves around nick's
clients all these hot wives he's banging
all these trainers and stuff they're
they're all they're keeping the wives in
shape
here's what goes on at our adult tick
tock house called the honey house
honey house god damn dude
so l.a the honey host
that dude he's from toronto for sure it
has to be yeah toronto yeah honey house
yeah we've got we've got a nice little
honey house
got a lot of a lot of good things going
on here at the honey house
and i can't even i think i think yeah
they're all just [ __ ] older people
in l.a yeah like they all have sugar
mamas and sugar daddies
have to be yeah i know i know there's
gonna be one dork who's like
you guys are just jealous yeah dude yes
we are
i want a rooftop yeah i want to be hot
with a rooftop and just
[ __ ] all the time on a rooftop dude i
want to have a sick body on a [ __ ]
fake grass rooftop yeah right that's an
experience i've
will never have having a hot ass body
working out on turf i'll never know what
that's like
yeah i'll just also could there be
anything easier content-wise than
posting a workout routine
oh yeah i'm sorry but you just pick four
exercises
the video only has to be a [ __ ]
minute long yeah you pick four
episode exercises that are somewhat
related you do those in a row on video
like you're gonna work out anyways you
might as well [ __ ] film it and then
post it and be like my new workout
routine
yeah and right yeah and the best thing
is dude about that
is when you're hot the content's
evergreen you know
there's seven billion people on this
earth there can be a new person every
day discovering that you're hot as [ __ ]
yeah it's like yes it just it just works
in your sleep and as as kids are born
and then they learn more about the
internet
your old bot your body that was filmed
10 years ago is [ __ ] evergreen
yeah people still talking about you know
um
uh who am i thinking about of oh my god
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on
wait wait i got it i got it i got it i
got it
jamie lee curtis okay people still talk
about jamie lee curtis young
she's 60 but you know they choose to
remember her in her 30s
yeah so yeah dude yeah
it's just easier for hot people it's
just everything's easier for hot people
all right look okay
look you open up that video right you
see nice body
felt rooftop your thoughts right away
are holy [ __ ] that person's hot
and they're rich yeah automatically i'm
going into this with
positive connotations okay you open up
one of my
videos right you say this guy is a
little bit chubby and he's
he's got cardboard boxes all over his
office and why does he seem like he's
perpetually sweating is that the
lighting
or is his forehead that's that shiny
exactly
exactly also yeah a little bit of you
know shave maybe between your eyes a
little bit more
you know also
bags under the eyes probably could get
more sleep okay right that's what you're
thinking
you're watching my video going in so
that's what it is
yeah and it's just easier for for the
hot people you know
everything's easier for hot people it's
stupid